wir haben das Gefühl wir werden bisschen
alleinelassen von der Politik auch als
Schüler auch als junge Menschen W des
Tages wir müssen in solche Entscheidung
auch mit einbezogen werden dass ist das
Beispiel von Studierenden aber darum
geht's gar nicht es ist das große Muster
das wir haben dass wir Entscheidungen
treffen in der Politik ohne die
Betroffenen einzubeziehen da werden wir
gleich noch zu kommen aber besonders in
der Bildungspolitik wir haben diesem
Land 11 Millionen Schülerinnen und
Schüler das ist eine Expertise das ist
ein Top von Expertise da erwarten wir
ganz klar dass die Bildungspolitik
könnte weitermchen ich könnte jetzt
einfach sagen Bauern gleiches Thema ja
ist klar aber die die Lobby ist anderen
Lobbies werden ja natürlich auch gehört
wir Schüler wir sind halt nicht die
lautesten wir haben keine große Lobby
aber wir sind mindestens genauso
bedeutend nicht zuletzt auch weil wir in
der Demokratiekrise stecken und die
Schüler von heute das sind die wler von
morgen W die Schüler heute wenn wir
heute jetzt für eine Drohung na ja na ja
aber wenn wir Schüler heute in die
Politik einbezogen werden und wir merken
wir können die Demokratie mitgestalten
wir werden einbezogen wir haben
Gestaltungsspielräume dann sendet es
natürlich auch das Signal dass die
Demokratie auch versucht Leute zu
beteiligen wenn wir es aber nicht tun
dann schießt die Politik verdußenheit
durch die Decke wie wie spürt ihr das an
der Schule wenn wenn sie sagen
da gibt's eine Gefahr für die Demokratie
also sagen dieses störgefühl dass so
viele im Moment haben dass irgendwie die
Dinge nicht so richtig gut laufen Markus
öder sagte gestern wir brauchen ein
neues deutschlandgefühl ich meine das
meint er und damit ungefähr wo merken
Sie das an der Schule ja dies diese
grundsätzliche Frage der Partizipation
die fängt ja nicht nur in der
Schülervertretung an nicht nur in der
bundesschülerkonferenz es fängt ja da an
wenn ich mal unterrichte und ich als
Schüler eine Idee habe und dem Lehrer
sage ja können wir nicht mal das und das
machen dann aber merke dass diese Idee
von den Verantwortungsträgern in dem
Fall meiner Lehrkraft gar nicht
berücksichtigt wird dann fühle ich mich
ja auch vorgekaspert insofern das fängt
auf dieser unteren Ebene an das geht
dann aber auch in die politische
Vertretung und sonst wo dann merken wir
dass wir Schüler werden bevormundet wir
werden belehrt aber diese Einbildung wer
bevormund das Gefühl hatte ich auch
immer aber an welcher Stelle habt ihr
das warum ja we eben wir Entscheid also
wenn ich mit einem Politiker z.B rede
dann merke ich ganz oft dass mir dass
ich da sitze nicht weil mir zugehört
werden soll sondern weil es heißt ich
erkläre dir mal was ich erkläre dir mal
wie es funktionieren sollte so dieses
paternalistische von oben runter gen ich
erkläre dir jetzt was ist das das Gefühl
das Gefühl ist es auf jeden Fall und ich
sage ja nicht dass wir jungen Leute mit
fertigen Konzepten wohingehen sollte ich
geh nicht mit ein Politiker und sagt ich
habe den Gesetzentwurf XY bring setzt
den jetzt mal so um nein aber wir können
trotzdem Impulse setzen wir können
Prioritäten setzen wir können auf Dinge
aufpiel mal konkret z.B z.B nehmen wir
Schultoiletten das ist ein Thema das ist
banal das ist nicht so
nicht banal es ist gar nicht banal in
der Tat es ist aber nicht so sexy wie
z.B KI anschulen und es wird es wird oft
vernachlässigt und da können wir Schüler
sagen guck mal gucken Sie mal Frau
starwzinger das ist ein Thema das wird
nicht berücksichtigt weil es vielleicht
einfach hinten runterfällt und oft sind
die Prioritäten in der Politik das ist
ja kein Geheimnis anders als das was
wirklich da draußen passiert und da sind
wir Schüler auch so ein bisschen so ein
frühahnystem aber ist das nicht jetzt
geht genau der Punkt guck er zu Eva
Quadbeck da würde dann jetzt Frau
starkzinger sagen ja n dafür ist ist ja
Frau PR verantwortlich also für das Klo
was habe ich damit zu tun also ja genau
also für die Finanzierung und
Ausstattung der Schulen sind tatsächlich
die Länder zuständig also das müsste
dann der Ball müsste dann an Frau PR
gespielt werden was die Schultoiletten
Angt die Schulträger sind zuständig aber
ich würde ich würde ich würde das
arument jetzt nicht bringen aber Moment
was das aber was das Klima an Schulen
angeht dafür sind vor allen Dingen die
Schulleitungen zuständig also wenn von
einer Schulleitung das Signal ausgeht an
die Lehrer wir möchten dass die Schüler
partizipieren
m dieung wir durchgesetzt und bei
Schulleitungen da muss ich jetzt sagen
kann ich nur so aus meinen eigenen
empirischen Werten berichten wenn da mal
an der Schule ein Lehrer eine
Schulleitung nachbesetzt wurde hatte ich
immer den Eindruck dass es wirklich um
alles mögliche geht aber nicht unbedingt
um konzeptionelle Stärke und
Qualifikation der Person die das dann am
Ende geworden ist
und meine Erfahrung im Leben also mit te
und das ist was sicherlich dann auch die
länderem sie da genauer hingucken wie
machen die Kommunen das eigentlich
regeln könnten und wenn man da dann
einen Geist in einem Bundesland kreiert
dass man sagt unsere Schulen die sollen
so gut sein dass die Schüler da
partizipieren und das irgendwie Konsens
wird in dem Land da käme dann käme man
dann durchaus voran bei dem Thema aber
ich muss sagen während Corona war es
unheimlich wichtig wir unterstützen ja
auch die bundesschülerkonferenz dass das
einfach ein bisschen Struktur da ist
kennen Sie beide sich wir haben uns
jetzt einmal kennengelernt ist ja noch
relativ neu und nächste Woche treffen
wir uns wir arbeiten zusammen ja genau
wir will n mal wissen also gibt gibt ein
ausus Hesse ist ja besonders gut ja gut
verbindet uns das tiefe hessische
heimatgefühlau woll gerade sagen der er
kennt sich natürlich sofort auch in
bösen Berlin nein aberteriner was ich
sagen wollte ist da war für uns
unheimlich wichtig in Corona also
natürlich für die Länder auch aber auch
Ansprechpartner zu haben der
Schülerinnen und Schüler die auch eine
gewisse Legitimation haben für die
Schüler gesprochen haben oder Bildung
für nachhaltige Entwicklung ist etwas
was wirklich fast ausschließlich von den
Schülerinen und Schülern auch
organisiert wird wo wir die Plattformen
zur Verfügung stellt weil genau das was
gesagt ist richtig ist und da steckt
auch unheimlich viel Kraft drin ist es
ist es nicht irgendwie traurig dass wir
ich weiß nicht wie oft wir äh das
Beispiel des Toiletten
Zustandes irgendwie hier in der Sendung
schon besprochen haben sei seit Jahren
eigentlich dass wir immer noch über
solche Banalitäten sprechen ja also
vielleicht
bei uns hestein ist es so dass wir nicht
nur verschiedene toilettenprogramme
gehabt haben zur toilettensanierung aber
da will ich jetzt gar nicht drüber reden
V Land nee das sage ich nicht dass alle
gut sind aber die meisten sind gut weil
wir sie eben finanziert haben und zwar
länderseitig obwohl die Schulträger
zuständig sind ich verstehe auch dass
man als Schüler sagt es mir doch völlig
egal wer da zuständig ist Bund Land
Kommunen ihr seht zu dass es klappt
verstehe ich ist auch ist auch legitim
trotzdem gibt's natürlich Aufgaben und
Finanzierungsverantwortung aber da das
ist mir gar nicht das wichtig s das
wichtigste ist bei uns gibt's eine
Parität in der Schüler in der
Schulkonferenz wir verpflichten die
Schulen schülerfeedback zu machen das
ist und die Schulen tun sich schwer
damit das weiß ich also es ist für
manchen Lehrer für manche Lehrkraft
immer noch ein sozusagen ein sakrilik
dass sie sich bewerten lassen müssen
von von Schülern aber das gehört ehrlich
gesagt zu ein modernen schulkur dazu und
Frau Quadbeck hat natürlich recht was
machen Sie wenn die sich schwer tun also
wenn sich jetzt ein Lehrer
Lehrerin verweigert und sagt ich lass
mich aber nicht bewerten na wir haben
wir haben gesagt ein Jahr könnte das
freiwillig machen mit dem
schülerfeedback und dann stellen wir es
verpflichtend und das ist jetzt
Gegenstand der
aufsichtsgespräche mit den
schulaufsichten und die Schüler die
Schulen müssen ab einem bestimmten Punkt
nachweisen wie sie das schülerfeedback
umsetzen und jetzt ziehen alle Lehrer
mit na ja die meisten ziehen mit eben
nicht immer alle also wer nicht mitzieht
was ist dann das ist eine
Führungsaufgabe der Schulleitung und
wenn die Schulleitung es nicht schafft
dann ist es die Schulaufsicht die die da
aktiv sag verpflichtend ja natürlich und
wenn das die Lehrer dann nicht machen na
ja und noch mal 30 000
Lehrkräfte natürlich gibt es immer
einzelne in so einem System wie in
anderen großen Systemen auch die Dinge
ungern machen oder nicht gut machen
wieder will ich machen und dann gibt's
die ganz große Mehrheit der Lehrkräfte
die machen das mit riesigem Engagement
und die machen es toll
ja Sie können sich aber in der
momentanen Situation auch nicht leisten
jemanden rauszuschmeißen ne ja das
können sie im Beamtenverhältnis ohnehin
ja gar nicht ähm und selbst im
Angestellten Verhältnis im öffentlichen
Dienst ist das ja eher schwierig das ist
eine Führungsaufgabe ähm die von den
Schulleitungen äh gelöst werden muss
deshalb ist auch der die
schulleiteraufgabe so anspruchsvoll und
deshalb haben sie recht Schulleiter
dürfen nicht besetzt werden etwa nach
politischen Vorlieben oder persönlichen
Vorlieben da muss es nach Leistung und
befegung gehen und das machen nur sie
jetzt in schlesig-holstad oder läuft das
deutschlandweit sicher unterschiedlich
von den Schwerpunkten wir sind ja haben
ja 16 Bundesländer und jedes Bundesland
macht da so das was es für richtig fr
wenn die Farbe wechselt dann wird's
andersrum gemacht ist ist ist das das
wenn sie meinen wenn sie sagen Frau
Quadbeck wir haben in der
Bildungspolitik vor allen Dingen ein
Umsetzungsproblem wir wissen woran es
liegt aber wir tun nicht genug ja wir
wissen seit 20 Jahren woran es liegt
2001 gab es den ersten pesaschock ich
kann mich da noch gut dran erinnern weil
da habe ich mich angefangen mit
politischer Berichterstattung aber das
weiß g nicht da damals aus den
Geschichtsbüchern damals damals galt das
noch als Gedöns bekam ich halt die
Bildungspolitik ähm und schon damals
waren die Schlagzeilen die
Kultusministerkonferenz ist eine
Schildkröte und die Entscheidung dauern
zu lang und wenn ich mir dann heute das
Interview von
Frau prEN anschaue dass sie in dieser
Woche gegeben hat dann sagt sie die
Entscheidungen in der
Kultusministerkonferenz dauern zu lang
und wenn man sich die Pisa Ergebnisse
anguckt von vor gut 20 Jahren und von
heute dann gab es zwischendrin 2012 mal
ein Piak da waren wir besser wie sage
ich mal ein schlechter Schüler ja der
Eine fünf schreibt dann rauft rafft er
sich auf schreibt eine zwei und dann
saagt alles wieder in sich zusammen und
dann sind die schlechten Noten wieder da
und genauso ist das leider mit den PIs
Studien aber frck die sich ja exzellent
auskennt auch in der Entwicklung
zwischen 2002 oder 2000 und heute weiß
natürlich auch ganz genau dass
dazwischen 2006 eine Föderalismusreform
gelegen hat und eine KMK Reform in die
KMK massiv ich will jetzt mal Kultus
Kultusministerkonferenz sozusagen wenn
man leinhaft könnte man sagen entmachtet
worden ist und wir ein
Wettbewerbsföderalismus mit nach 2006
eingeführt haben der gerade die
Kooperation zwischen den Ländern die ja
so dringend erforderlich wäre um mehr
Vereinheitlichung zu schaffen gerade die
ist ja 2006 außer Kraft gesetzt worden
also es ist immer das was man bestellt
das kriegt man auch und ich glaube die
Föderalismusreform im im Bildungsbereich
ist ein krasser Fehler gewesen damals
von einer großen Koalition ja verabredet
worden in letzter Minute als bargin also
sozusagen als als Gegenleistung für
irgendwas anderes was man da miteinander
verabreden wollte das ist ein großer
Fehler gewesen und dann haben sie sehr
beschrieben bis 2012 sind die Ergebnisse
nach oben gegangen weil die KMK
natürlich was gemacht hat und dann ist
man faul geworden tatsächlich ist man
faul geworden und dann kommt noch hinzu
dass sich die Schülerschaft seit 2012 in
Deutschland massiv verändert hat wir
haben in deutlich ansteigenden Anteil an
Kindern mit mit Zuwanderungshintergrund
wir haben aber auch insgesamt
bei dem Nachwuchs den wir in Deutschland
haben eine Veränderung mit Blick auf die
soziale Schichtung es sind nicht nur die
Kinder mit Zuwanderungshintergrund und
wir haben völlig verändertes
Elternverhalten
ähm Eltern sind insgesamt äh in ihrem
Erziehungsverhalten deutlich
verändert was was heißt das was heißt
das das fängt an mit dem mit dem Zugang
zu sozialen Medien und zu ähm zu
digitalen Endgeräten und so weiter was
mein sprechen Sie na ich spreche vom
erziehungsveralten der Eltern was ich
nicht zu bewerten habe aber wo man
konkret sagen sprechen Sie jetzt einfach
gerade ich sprech das jetztus wir sind
ja ganz unter uns z. Lesen immer weniger
Eltern ihren Kindern etwas vor im im
Kleinkind Alter im Grundschulalter das
hat massive Auswirkung das anekdotisch
oder ist das empirisch belegt sind das
ist das ist das sind Studien klare
Studien und wie wie wie s wie ist da die
die Datenlage also dass wir inzwischen
rund 40% der Eltern haben die ihr Kälte
Eltern selten oder gar nicht mehr
Vorlesen das ist eine dramatische
Entwicklung wir haben was noch mobile
Endgeräte die die Mediennutzung übgens
nicht nur der Kinder sondern auch der
Eltern spielt eine große Rolle Eltern
sind oftmals auch selber sehr
beschäftigt okay was hat das mit der
Schule zu tun das hat was mit nee das
hat was damit zu tun wie Kinder wie
Eltern ihre Kinder ziehen ähm und was
Eltern ihren Kindern mitgeben
ähm ähm wenn es darum geht guten Start
in in eine Bildungsbiographie zu kommen
zu bekommen
und dann haben wir natürlich auch immer
mehr Kinder die die deutsche der
deutschen Sprache nicht mächtig sind
wenn sie in die Schule kommen immer mehr
Kinder die ein oder mehrere Elternteile
haben die eben kein Deutsch sprechen das
ist übrigens und das soll ich zu sagen
das ist nicht Schuld der Kinder und das
rechtfertigt überhaupt nichts das
Bildungssystem muss sich darauf
einstellen also nicht dass wir uns
falsch verstehen ich will das überhaupt
nicht ir als Entschuldung oder so
darstellen aber es heißt das
Bildungssystem muss sich wasiv verändern
und die Veränderungen sind eben nicht
schnell genug passiert sie sie dürfen
sofort aber ich schaue schon die ganze
Zeit zu Florian und ich ich sehe auch
das
Kopfschütteln nein nein gerne ja ja weil
äh der Vorwurf kommt häufig und ich weiß
wie genervt ihr davon seid wenn dann
sozusagen wieder dieser Vorwurf kommt
spielt es jetzt einfach mal zu also ihr
mit euren elenden Smartphones das geht
so nicht weiter und
das das ist sozusagen entweder sind
Computerspiele oder Smartphones und das
ist der Untergang der Jugend von heute
nein nicht der Jugend ren über kinderer
und grundchüler Spitze gerade zu würd
gerne mal verstehen was die Perspektive
eines Schülers ist der hier sitzt der
der Vorwurf ist mit Verlaub komplett
absurd wir haben eine Digitalisierung
die ist nicht nur zu langsam sondern wir
digitalisieren auch einfach schlichttig
falsch jetzt als Pisa die Ergebnisse
rauskamen und dann Schweden hat auch
angefangen jetzt Digitalisierung in
Grundschulen etwas zurückzufahren D habe
ich aus allen Ecken gehört wir müssen
Handys aus den Schulen verbanden wir
müssen digitale aus den schulenverband
und das ist das ist komplett naiv wir
sind im 21 es geht nicht mehr sie
sprechen Schweden an deswegen das ist
auch ganz interessant zu wissen ne
Schweden auch da gab es Schock darüber
wie der Leistungsabfall der schwedischen
Kinder auch ist ja und wir denken immer
weil Skandinavien so toll ist müssen wir
das auch so machen aber wir sollten uns
nicht die Frage stellen ob wir
digitalisieren DAF kein Weg dran vorbei
wir sollten uns eher die Frage stellen
wie digitalisieren wir meine Schwester
ist jetzt in der neunen klasse und die
14-jährigen haben iPads hingelegt
bekommen weil Digitalisierung ist ja
wichtig sie haben nie erklärt bekommen
wie man damit um
äht und anderechä dies mediild diet
nicht vom Himmel aber dieses mindset
herrcht gerade in der Politik und da
brauchen wir auch proaktivere
Medienbildung die die Schulen geht und
den Schülern erklärt wie geht man
eigentlich damit um und wie kann man das
eigentlich auch Nutzen für den eigenen
lnerfolg und das passiert gerade quasi
gar nicht das bestreite ich also in
dieser Pauschalität stimt ein H ja wir
hängen in Deutschland hinterher ich
glaub da sind wir uns dann schnell einig
aber wir haben wahnsinnig aufgeholt in
den letzten Jahren und wenn es um
Handynutzung geht dann reden wir über
Kitas und wir reden über Grundschulen
niemand würde auf die Idee kommen zu
sagen wir müssen wir müssen digitale
Tools oder gar digitale Endgerät aus den
Schulen verbannen darum geht es doch gar
nicht es geht um den richtigen da sind
wir uns sehr einig es geht um den
richtigen und einen mehrwertbringenden
Einsatz Digitalität ist kein Wert an und
für sich sondern Digitalität ist ein
Instrument und das muss vernünftig und
pädagogisch gut eingesetzt werden nur
darum geht es und da gibt es nach
Nachholbedarf bei den Lehrkräften
richtig aber daan arbeiten wir halt
intensiv und ich glaub wir sind da
wahnsinnig viel vorangekommen in den
letzten Jahren würde gerne noch mal Eva
Quadbeck fragen was Frau pring gerade
hier gemacht hat das war ja sehr
interessant muss man sich trauen ne du
legst dich sozusagen erstmal mit
Schülern an du legst dich aber auch
gleich mit den Eltern an und du redest
über ein sehr vergiftetes Thema genau
dieses Thema Umgang mit sozialen Medien
die Frage wie das die Gesellschaft
verändert die Frage wie das
Erziehungsarbeit verändert das ist kein
Thema mit dem man sehr viele Wähler
begeistert weil viele spüren da gibt es
etwas und wir sollten uns da mal ehrlich
machen als Gesellschaft warum führen wir
solche Debatten nicht häufiger ganz
ehrlich und und ohne ideologische
Schablonen weil es jetzt gerade bei der
Debatte Erziehungsfrage ist es natürlich
schwierig überhaupt eine politische
Debatte zu führen weil die Erziehung von
Kindern ist
Privatsache a aus gutem Grund ja aus
gutem Grund Sache der Eltern und erst
wenn Eltern ganz offensichtlich mit den
Kindern nicht klar kommen erst dann ist
der Staat auch aus gutem Grund befugt da
einzugreifen was die Eltern
angeht ist das Bild glaube ich sehr
heterogen es gibt sicherlich eine Gruppe
da spricht man ja dann von der
Generation Rücksicht auch von Kindern
die sehr sehr gut behütet sind wo ich
sogar manchmal das Gefühl habe dass
Eltern sogar versuchen Kinder vor zu
viel Leistungsdruck in Schutz zu nehmen
wo Eltern auch sehr hinterher sind dass
Kinder überhaupt nicht so viele mobile
Endgeräte haben dann gibt es diejenigen
die tendenziell eher laufen lassen und
sagen die Schule die soll man machen die
Schule ist dafür zuständig also auch zu
viel Anspruchshaltung an die Schule
haben im Sinne von das ist
reparat g genau das ist dann der
Reparaturbetrieb für das wo man sich zu
Hause nicht mehr wo man zu Hause nicht
mehr so viel Lust hatte sich die Mühe zu
geben es ist bestimmt hilfreich wenn man
eine Debatte darüber führt und auch sagt
was ist eigentlich elternaufgabe also
das als Gesellschaft müssen wir das doch
mal verhandeln das genau das aufs
Tableau zu bringen das ist auf jeden
Fall wichtig und
was ich aber auch noch sagen möchte an
der Stelle wir schaffen es ja seit 20
Jahren nicht diese Schere die eben zu
Beginn des Jahrtausends erkannt wurde
zwischen den Kindern aus bildungsnahen
und bildungsfernen Haushalten äh zu
schließen und die Kinder aus
bildungsnahen Haushalten die können
wahrscheinlich auch relativ viel zocken
und kommen trotzdem gut durch die Schule
weil sie es nämlich trotzdem mit
mitbekommen von zu Hause und die aus
bildungsfernen Haushalten da richtet das
möglicherweise zu viel ähm Konsum
sozialer Medien und zu viel Konsum von
Spielen führt dazu dass sie erst recht
nicht sich auf die Schule konzentrieren
können da glaube ich muss man auch
einfach differenzieren und deshalb muss
man viel mehr auch noch da ansetzen wie
schließen wir eigentlich diese Schere
aus bildungsnahen und
bildungsfernenhaushalten zumal die die
Diagnose ist ja richtig dass es
inzwischen mehr Kinder gibt die
Schwierigkeiten haben oder wo das
Elternhaus denen das nicht mehr so
mitgeben kann und da denke ich muss man
ganz früh ansetzen nämlich tatsächlich
im Kindergarten im kitaalter und gucken
ob die Kinder überhaupt die Fähigkeit
haben eingeschult zu werden und wenn sie
die Fähigkeit nicht haben was man durch
Tests rausfinden kann dass man da dann
auf jeden Fall schon Hilfe anbietet und
wenn man dann am anderen Ende der Schule
darauf schaut dass jedes Jahr rund
50.000 Jugendliche ohne Schulabschluss
die Schule verlassen mus muss man sich
leisten ne als Land dann 50.000 jedes
Jahr die ohne Abschluss die Schule
verlassen 50 60.000 die dann am
Arbeitsmarkt nicht wirklich zubrauchen
sind und wir haben wir haben aber in
Deutschland einen Reparaturbetrieb der
das durchaus auffängt jeder kriegt ja
neue Chancen dann doch sein
Schulabschluss zu machen in Ausbildung
zu gehen nur das ist ja relativ teuer
und es wäre viel sinnvoller auch da das
Geld zu verlagern und in der zehnten
Klasse den Kindern und Jugendlichen die
drohen ohne Schulabschluss die Schule zu
verlassen richtiges Coaching an die
Seite zu stellen aber neben dem neben
dem Frage Fachkräfte aber auch
persönlicher Lebensweg was sie gerade
angesprochen haben hat es auch ein
demokratiefaktor weil wir eingangs
darüber sprach chen wir sehen ja also
max blan Institut hat neulich auch
Zahlen gezeigt dass wenn Bildung
bröckelt das Misstrauen in Institutionen
steigt das heißt es hat auch was damit
zu tun wo geht unsere Gesellschaft hin
natürlich auch Wachstum und Wohlstand
aber auch wie entwickelt sich die
Diskussion in unserer Gesellschaft und
das Demokratieverständnis insofern
stimmt es schon das was Florian
Fabritius natürlich eingangs sagte dass
Bildung als dieser Grundstock gesehen
wird und das ist er ja auch weil er so
viel bedient ne Lebensweg Wachstum und
Wohlstand und Demokratie tiefverständnis
Frau PR und dann ich habe jetzt die
Debatte angezettelt ehrlich gesagt aus
einem ganz bestimmten Grund weil ich
darauf hinweisen wollte dass wir über
Bildung und Erziehung sprechen Bildung
und Erziehung sind Aufgabe zu VST der
Eltern übrigens und dann des Staates und
natürlich da wo der
wo Familien das nicht hinkriegen nicht
schaffen
nicht wollen oder nicht können
da muss der Staat natürlich stärker
eingreifen und deshalb muss Schule auch
heute ganz anders sein wir haben immer
immer noch in Deutschland sehr stark Z
ein Bild von Schule in Schule wird
Wissen vermittelt die etwas moderneren
sagen in Schule wird Kompetenz
vermittelt
im besten Fall sollte es ja beides sein
aber in Wahrheit brauchen brauchen wir
natürlich auch immer mehr
Erziehungsleistung an Schule deshalb
brauchen wir auch ein ganz anderes
Personaltableau wir brauchen nicht mehr
nur Lehrer an Schule weil diese
Erziehungsleistungen die müssen eben
auch andere bringen nicht an dem
Hochbegabten Gymnasium da braucht man
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viele
obwohl die psychische Situation quer
durch die Bank von Jugendlichen egal aus
welchen sozialen Schichten sie kommt
heute jedenfalls eine angespanntere ist
ne also das Thema psychische Gesundheit
ist ja auch eins was ich jedenfalls
unsere landeschüler Vertretung ganz
stark auf die auf die fahren geschrieben
hat ich glaube die die
bundesschülerkonferenz auch ähm deshalb
muss Schule grundsätzlich sich verändern
mit Blick auf die Angebote äh die sie
machen die Lebensrealitäten und das
bedeutet und das können wir nur schaffen
mäh auch was die Ressourcen angeht also
das heißt was Geld und vor allem
Menschen angeht die das leisten wenn wir
die Systeme Jugendhilfe eingielungshilfe
und Schule näher be aninander braen sie
Personal Frau PR ja aber ehrlich gesagt
wir brauchen Personal wir brauchen auch
mehr Personal aber wir haben ganz viel
Personal
rund um das Kind und den Jugendlichen
nur wir setzen es eben nicht in
Kooperation ein wir habenit WN haben wir
genug Personal in der Jugendhilfe in der
Eingliederungshilfe wissen Sie wie viel
Schulbegleitung wir zum Teil an unseren
Schulen im Rahmen der Inklusion haben da
ist jeder einzelne zuständig für ein
Kind wir haben zum Teil fünf sechs
Schulbegleitung in einer Klasse sitzen
sie sie haben doch gerade ihre ihre
Klassenstärke erhöht oder nicht wir
haben für
dieklassen für die sogenannten
datzklassen haben was ist das was ist
das das datz ist die Abkürzung für
Deutsch als zweisprache dort haben wir
jetzt was heißt das übersetzt das sind
die Klassen in denen Kinder die aus
Flucht oder aus anderen Gründen aus dem
Ausland herkommen und kein Deutsch
können indem die die erste Zeit
verbringen um sozusagen intensiv Deutsch
zu lernen und die haben sie erhöht von
16 auf 18 richtig im Kopf in Meckel vorp
sind 25 wir sind jetzt noch deutlich
unter dem
unter dem Bundes Durchschnitt Stopp wie
alt sind diese Kinder von fünf oder
sechs wenn sie in der ersten Klasse sind
bis
16 wenn sie in der zehnten Klasse sind
und wir reden auch da zum wiederholten
nein also wobei die sind dann in
Jahrgangsstufen eingeteilt ne also die
sitzen nicht von von von 6 bis 16 in
einer Klasse sondern schon klar aber die
die die die die die Stärke wird erhöht
sozusagen die die die Zahl derer die da
drin sitzt geht nach oben na ja Herr LZ
wir haben in den letzten 4 Jahren haben
wir fast 700 zusätzliche Lehrkräfte im
datzbereich einstellen müssen weil wir
haben so dramatisch ansteigende Zahlen
im im geflüchteten Bereich dass wir
einfach so viel zusätzliche Lehrkräfte
brauchen und wir brauchen auch noch
zusätzliche Lehrkräfte weil insgesamt ja
auch die Geburtenzahlen ansteigen das
heißt unser lehrkräftebedarf explodiert
und gleichzeitig haben wir ja eine
Fachkräfte Krise die sich gewaschen hat
also das also darf ich noch mal fragen
bei Inklusion da ist jetzt jemand da ein
Mensch der sozusagen diese eine
Schülerin diesen einen Schüler begleitet
ein ein Verhältnis gen genau dafür sind
übrigens dann die die K in einer Klasse
ne bitte bis zu sechs ja das ist jetzt
eineähte das das ist eine es können auch
mehr sein es können auch weniger sein ja
okay aber das ist eine sozusagen sehr
direkte unmittelbare Betreuung genau und
W wir uns doch alle einig sind in dem
Befund wie wie wie wie essentiell
Sprache ist wenn wir dann noch zweitens
hören dass 40% ihren Kindern auch gar
nicht mehr Vorlesen also merken Sprache
ist noch viel wichtiger also das
Augenmerk auf Sprache zu legen
Sprachvermittlung wie wie wie wie passt
dann dazu dass wir dann die die die
Klassenstärke erhöhen genau an diesem
neuralgischen Punkt ja Entschuldigung in
Hessen sind ist die Klassenstärke
20 und wir erhöhen jetzt auf 18 und wir
haben darüber hinaus in schig heolin
eben anders als viele andere
Bundesländer nicht 20 Wochenstunden
sondern 25 Wochenstunden und ehrlich
gesagt ich kriege keine Leute mehr also
doch es gibt ja das ist nee nee es gibt
so viele Lösungen für den
Lehrkräftemangel da draußen man kann
pensionierte Lehrkräfte wieder zurück
man kanninsteiger haben man kann
ausländische Abschlüsse besser etc aber
es kann doch nicht sein dass wenn wir
jetzt schon Klassen haben mit zum Teil
25 30 Schülern dass S das noch mehr
hochschauen noch mehr we von individuell
von 16 auf 18 Kinder pro Klasse nicht 25
oder 30 Anspruch den wir uns selber
haben zu sagen so auf das erhöhen wir
jetzt ich bitte ich werfe ihn das nicht
persönlich vor wir diskutieren über eine
Struktur und wir sind sozusagen auf der
Spur dieser
Bildungsmisere und und sagen seit 20
Jahren diskutieren wir das und ehrlich
gesagt wird's nicht besser es wird immer
schlechter na das stimmt ja nicht haben
vorher rausgearbeitet es ist ja zunächst
deutlich besser geworden und wir sind
jetzt auch noch übrigens über dem Niveau
von 2000 das wird zwar alles immer haben
sie vorhin auch anders aniert aber das
stimmt ja nicht Flor
schüttelt Grafen da gesehen es gibt
Kompetenz da sind wir ein bisschen
drüber aber im ganzen großen der Trend
ist schlecht ich will das jetzt auch
nicht ich will das jetzt auch nicht
nicht schön das ist noch nicht gut nee
aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so dass wir
überall schlechter sind als 2000 aber
darum geht es gar nicht es ist schlecht
und der Trend ist schlecht und das kann
doch nicht der Anspruch für ein Land sie
könen ein hochindustrieland wie
Deutschland sein nein das ist auch nicht
der das ist geht nicht darum ob es der
Anspruch ist wir müssen besser werden
wir müssen die Trendwende schaffen aber
wir müssen natürlich die Stellen auch
besetzen können und wir und ich ich habe
in meinem Land ich mach das seit 2017
ich habe tausende von zusätzlichen
Lehrerstellen geschaffen und auch
besetzt aber wir kommen an unsere
Grenzen das ich meine das da können Sie
jetzt sagen das ist nicht unser Anspruch
aber es ist so